to introduce today's topic what I want
to do is call your mind back to
something you learned about right-angled
triangles before treeger came on the
scene what was the first main thing that
we spent lots of time doing in your 8 to
do with right-angled triangles
Pythagoras very good and we love
Pythagoras because we're good at it
right and you've been using it ever
since and we keep on using Pythagoras is
a wonderfully versatile yeah ok now I
actually want you to remember when you
see questions like this you often see
the same numbers over and over again as
the lengths that come up in right angled
triangles the same numbers seem to get
recycled repeatedly three numbers for
three sides can anyone give me an
example or three numbers you'll hear a
lot three four and five three four five
is the most common one but there are
others as well what else do you get
apart from three four and five one two
three is not a right-angled triangle
some will give me another one or close
five twelve thirteen s another one five
twelve thirteen twelve eight fifteen
seventeen maybe seven 24 25 anyhow my
point is I'll just wait for everyone's
attention when you're ready goes my
question to you is why is it why over
and over again for all the millions and
billions of numbers that are out there
in the world why do we keep giving you
the same ones over and over again here's
why we keep getting the same ones if for
example you just choose very slightly
different numbers okay you guys know
Pythagoras can you work out what the
hypotenuse will be in this case okay so
here when you square this you get nine
you square this you get 36 36 Plus 9 is
45 so what does that have to do with the
hypotenuse it's a square root of 45 now
the square root of 45 is the square root
of 45 you can get a decimal expansion
for it but it
to disaster what did you say was tuition
six point okay thank you very much and
the decimals go on forever okay so this
is a what do we call these numbers right
when this decimal goes on forever and
never repeats it has a name mr. Val it's
a set right and a rational number it's
just gross it's we don't want to deal
with them we want to try and avoid them
okay usually when we're assisting you
guys on Pythagoras's theorem we're not
about assisting you on this so we keep
the numbers nice and neat now in trig
ratios you've got a similar kind of
thing except it's not sides its angles
there are certain angles that pop up in
right-angled triangles over and over
again and they give you nice numbers for
your trig ratios for sine cos and ten so
I'm going to tell you what these nice
numbers are just like with um pythagoras
houses three sites conveniently there
are three angles so three nice angles as
we will learn later on there are
actually more but these three are the
ones that come first they're 30 45 and
60 30 45 and 60 now why should these be
the angles that come up over and over
again as we draw some triangles that
include them you will see why they raise
45 60 this one has come up quite a few
times can you get your calculator out
get your calculator out and I want you
to test out for me you might even
remember what is sine of 30 degrees sine
of 30 it should be exactly 1/2 which is
weird because usually if you try sine of
anything even sine of these numbers here
you get some weird decimal rubbish out
there like this okay so this guy is kind
of like the nicest ratio out there it's
equal to exactly 1/2 which means that
just like with Pythagoras
I can draw a right-angled triangle that
has this at its core what will the right
angle triangle look like I need some
more space underneath this I want you to
draw a triangle where you've gotten a
30-degree angle but opposite you can
actually measure this out Opera
your angle you've got a side that's one
length and it could be one centimeter or
it could be ten centimeters or something
like that
and you've got a hypotenuse that's
exactly twice as long okay so for
example I might measure out in my book a
length maybe three centimeters okay and
I'll make this guy the opposite side
okay where would the hypotenuse go it
would be like over here right and I want
it to be if this guy's three then how
long do I want the hypotenuse to be
double it is six so go ahead get your
ruler you twist it around and you draw
it so that that was a six centimeter
line that would be the hypotenuse if
you've done that what you should find is
when you complete the right angle
triangle what you'll find is that this
angle over here has to be 30 degrees you
had no protractor but if sine 30 equals
1/2 then opposite by hypotenuse 3 on 6
is 1/2 okay so if this is the case this
is my one side and this is my two side I
now need to use Pythagoras again to find
out what the last side is now we were
trying to avoid thirds before but we
treat what we're looking at is nice
angles so I can work out what this last
side is this squared is going to be 4
this squared is going to be 1 so what
will this side be the square root of 3
right because if the square root of 3
then a squared plus B squared will be 1
plus 3 which is C squared does that all
fit does that make sense so from here
I've got sine 30 but I can also get all
the other things as well I can get cos
30 and I can get tan 30 just by looking
at the sides in the triangle
where's coz 30 which parricides am i
interested in I'm interested in the
adjacent and the hypotenuse right
sohcahtoa so it's going to be adjacent
on hypotenuse which is root 3 on 2 now
it looks a bit weird because it's got a
square root unit
but this is an exact value when you go
in and you punch cause thirty into your
calculator go ahead do it when you put
in cause thirty it doesn't look like
anything you'd recognize but Pythagoras
tells us this has to be root 3 so
sohcahtoa tells us this has to be three
on two have a look at ten now which
sides am i interested in for ten
opposite over adjacent which is going to
be one on root three and you can go in
your calculator you can type in ten
thirty and then the person Dix you can
type in 1 over root 3 and sure enough
you get all the exact same decimal
places all the way to the end okay so
sine 30 cos 30 10 30 your calculator can
give you decimals but we can get the
exact values even with the certs okay so
that's much more powerful